the that mother effort isn't real lady
from the airplane is issuing an apology
hey everyone it's me Tiffany Gomez
as you know I
have been unwilling to speak on the
viral video but can we just pause it
this woman looks nothing like the woman
from the video
I'm not saying it's a different person
or Invasion of the Body Snatchers or
something but
I'm saying it because had this woman
just gone about her daily life no one
would have recognized her I don't know
she she darkened her hair a little bit
I'm sure she went through a tough time
after that video went viral but she's
deciding for some reason to make a big
public spectacle of herself again this
time I think probably more ill-advisedly
than the first time